The jogan
Experience oh boy split
split oh
SHO
wow you never seen a bookie with a
part-time job my
friend
wow
interesting I think me and Drake jinxed
stri yeah he's the kiss of [__] death
very
interesting I wonder how the people
online feel about that cuz you know
we're not scoring it while we're
watching it we're watching it we're just
having
fun were we
wrong man we watched this more it was
close man it was and you got three who
are these judges you know what I mean
you don't know who these judges are
listen fourth round he did
awesome wow I think I or Bo nickel eats
these guys lunch interesting bro how
about him versus
Hamot is shovot 185 or 170 70 70 how
about him versus Hamza UFC 300 Ramadan o
that's true [__] I know right well Hamza
fighting Ramadan he's crazy absolutely
not no nope won't do it n says he won't
do it that when is that I think it's all
of April right y they would be fighting
during Ramadan yeah but can't you just
sleep all day and then eat at night yeah
can't you do that at night can you just
adjust your s tough like like Mev said
absolutely
not
but I know that uh bal's done camps
through
Ramadan
yes
wow um Jamie what do the people online
think a lot of the uh like d is early
early rounds drias they gave the early
rounds to draas the commentary was lot
towards drias really
I'm just reading like the hash UFC 297
feed though it's just flying by so I'm
just sort of trying to
interesting they're going crazy in South
Africa lot Strickland got cheated
Strickland
won who's say random random people what
about um check Donald Trump
[Laughter]
Jr how about Luke Thomas yeah Luke
Thomas says good first round oh this is
26 minutes ago so
after
she said before it says uh this one's
going to be close I can see 48 47 either
direction as close on paper as we
imagined so he said the last two rounds
I definitely think he won the fourth but
you think he won the
fifth I don't know man the fifth seemed
like it was Sean was Landing more shots
whiffing a lot look at the copy strike
num too Sean land had [__] ton more
punches look at this
here so total strikes 154 to
116 um take down zero he got six sub
attempts no one got any uh significant
strikes 143 for Shawn versus 114 for
tus the thing about that though is like
a lot of them might have been in the
early rounds you just give them a 10
nine round round for those significant
strikes so it's not it's not necessarily
if you see like a big number like that
it doesn't necessarily mean that the guy
won the fight no if you're doing it the
right way interesting tough fight though
close F listen if Izzy wants to come
back and he wants to fight
drus let's run it back he said how about
a rematch at 300 they won't do that why
not if vagna can't can't make it that's
listen that's a good fight a rem match
that's a good fight quick turnar around
for rematch that's a very quick turn
around for either one of these guys
though if they're going to have a
rematch look if you have a split
decision loss that is one of the best
indication indications that it was a
close fight and the kind of fights you
want to see a rematch on are the ones
that are close fights I'd like to see
Izzy versus dup at 3 but still if Izzy
can't that as a rematch is very
compelling Stitch that [__] eye up
let's
go